2021 has been the year of the chicken
sandwich i mean there are thousands of
chefs all over social media who believe
that they've discovered the ultimate
secret ingredient and here to share his
own savory secret
is our dear friend the healthy chef dan
churchill
hi dan good to see you bro now i haven't
eaten chicken in 12 years so i haven't
been able to partake in this whole
chicken sandwich phenomenon but you're
gonna help me get there that's
absolutely right now to because you're
inspired and i'm inspired to make the
ultimate chickenless sandwich today
that's exactly what we're gonna do we're
gonna really set the bar at a high point
and yeah everyone's gonna be recreating
this at home because it is so simple to
do all right before we get started this
meal starts with a corn meatless
home-style chicken cutlet now corn is a
company that i work with i am the chief
mom officer i am very proud of that um
and i'm so excited that our show is
working with them too they have a
delicious selection of meat-free
products that are available at almost
every grocery store in the country you
just go to the freezer section they have
cutlets um they have roasts that's what
i made for thanksgiving now to prepare
these cutlets you're going to throw them
on a baking sheet at 400 degrees for
about 20 minutes but dan is the chef to
take through it so
so step number one as you just alluded
to is all about flavor and that's what
you're talking about right now one of
the coolest things about this sandwich
and why i love it so much is to make the
ultimate cashew aioli so like any good
uh use of a blender you want to use your
liquid base first so
that's right because that makes the
blades work better and faster 100 all
right so in go some almond milk like
this
and then on top of that we also have
some garlic oil now i'm a big fan of
infusing any oil and all you have to do
is just chop up some garlic and then add
that straight into a pan medium heat and
just let it sit there chill have some
wine relax maybe talk to your loved one
and let that flavor just infuse into
this beautiful oil so in goes that we've
also got here some white wine vinegar as
well the acid is going to really tie it
through so chuck that in so along with
that in goes some garlic powder along
with some turmeric okay also now this is
the secret ingredient we did say cashews
now typically miso paste is notorious
for asian cuisine but it holds such a
beautiful umami savory note so whenever
cooking with miso just know if you're
looking for a way of getting an extra
bit of that umaminess it's a great
alternative to add in and then of course
it also has a little bit of a nuttiness
which complements the cashew because
there's miso bean paste it's a soybean
pasta right yeah no they they're very
good friends exactly they hang out all
the time lid on okay now yep and then
where are we going which one you write
yeah i think puree and hit it hard
because it it's one of those
perfect
i feel like that was a formula one race
it was
i think you won though so anyway here
has our beautiful puree and this is what
i love about this kind of situation this
is a cacioli this is just simple to do
and mix in any other herbs or anything
else and you can make it honestly your
favorite pesto aioli or anything else so
you can take this to any direction you
want good
i think it's drill approved
that's always a weird so i'm sure i'm
just going to test anyway because i'm a
big fan of this can't wait to hear your
review oh wow that's actually epic yeah
epic
all right now you say that this slaw is
a game changer yeah i am a big slaw fan
teach me cool awesome so
typical slow in terms of ingredients
you've got your onion you've got your
cabbage you do have your carrot but
similarly with the actual dressing which
i feel is the big point of difference
we're going to take it down the cashew
route as well and i find a lot of
dressings i've had with ranch uh can be
really heavy yeah this is light and
still taking the same nutty effect so in
this over here we see the base
ingredients we have simply some garlic
powder again we've got some herbs in the
chives along with some dill like fresh
dills amazing the white one vinegar
olive oil
and honestly just like that simply the
same as the aioli it is that simple to
put in your wonderful blender and get it
done that's it i love that yeah so bring
it together i love a fresh tail i know
so
with that being said
we have the base of our ingredients now
to make this ultimate chickenless
sandwich that
hopefully drill proves of as the best
sandwich in the world okay so
settlement node now did you know there's
an art to building a sandwich
hold that frame it's it's just think
about for a second because
sandwiches can be so soggy
they can be dry but you have to have the
perfect combination of build it's like
you need a building to be having
beautiful foundations so teach me sure
so what you want to look for first is
with your ingredients you want to make
sure the creamy aspect and not the
liquid one is on the base so here we
have that wonderful slow we're talking
about as an example we also have here
our beautiful aioli we just created
earlier this is going to go perfect
because it's going to stop any drippage
of any liquid from that slaw seeping
through same with the pickle we have as
well so where's our bun here we have our
bun i'm just going to open it up like
that and simply going to put a dollop of
the thick
creamy paste we always have and then can
go on our pickle now that's actually got
a bit of residue of the liquid base so
that creamy aioli is preventing that
actual liquid base seeping through into
your bottom bun which is really
important so it's not going to get soggy
yes
i love that
that's brilliant thank you for
preventing my buns from getting soggy
dan
it's like a proud dad right here i know
so next goes on the slaw i'm 100 not
doing as if this is on my pass i'm just
kind of spooning it on and having some
fun with it as if i'm at home so in goes
the slaw next we're going to have our
actual bib lettuce so on goes our bib
lettuce then it goes the actual
wonderful chicken little situation right
here now this is which one's this
this is actually the chicken cutlets
speaking of meaningful endeavors you're
doing something with city harvest that's
a company i very much admired oh thank
you drew yeah so this company does two
things i absolutely love it helps
you know combats the idea of food waste
which unfortunately forty percent of our
food still in this city goes to waste
and the other thing is one in five new
yorkers don't know where their next meal
is coming from so city harvest combats
both those things by helping feed those
in need and then also on top of that
eliminating food waste which is pretty
pretty special
oh that's beautiful what you've done dan
all i did if you guys can see this i'll
give you a little angle where we're
going here there we go so all i've done
is i've actually cut about seven eighths
or three quarters maybe an easy way to
say it all the way through to the
avocado all i've done is then done it a
few times and press it down so you get
this nice little fan and then i'm just
going to put that right on top of the
sandwich
and then just gonna there you go
and then
bam that is
now
wow look at that
[Music]
how's my mouth am i going everywhere
it's so hard to put the sandwich i don't
know
i was like it's so good you guys but dan
i got to tell you
doesn't
[Music]
find this recipe
for this sandwich at the dreamery
and talk to us about worms
[Music]